(upbeat violin music)
- You lose your sight, and
everything gets a little harder.
Everything takes longer.
The walls seem to be caving
in on you all the time.
When I was introduced to blind sailing,
it was really an opportunity
for me to push the walls out,
to feel reconnected with the earth.
(upbeat violin music)
(upbeat harp music)
My name's Walt Raineri.
I'm the skipper of Blind
Match Racing Team USA 1,
for the Blind Match
Racing World Championships
here in Sheboygan, Wisconsin.
For myself as a visually
impaired individual
I'm looking forward to putting
a lot of this stuff
I've been thinking about
for the last couple of
months into practice.
You hold in and I'll kick off.
Tell me when.
- When we're racing, there's
no sighted people on the boat.
It's just the three blind crew members.
- You're relying on
other members of the crew
literally for your life.
It doesn't take long for
that bond to develop.
- This is the blue one right here,
so I push the blue fob button.
(blaring alarm)
(upbeat music)
- There's three buoys
in blind match racing.
Each of those buoys
makes a distinct sound.
- We listen for where the
buoys are on the water
and we navigate using
mental triangulation.
By basis of where we are
in relation to those buoys,
we know where we are in the water.
There are many times when the boats are
coming right at one another,
and we need to know where they are,
they need to know where we are.
(whistle)
Each of the boats has a sound emitter.
Vision is, by far, a human
being's predominant sense.
But you take away the vision,
the audio sense picks up real quick.
(beeping) There you go.
Pressure's feeling better now.
At times it feels like a
little bit of controlled chaos.
- Where are they, where are they?
- The truth of it is, with a good team,
and jibe ho,
everything is under control,
as chaotic as it may look.
(upbeat music)
About 12 years ago now, just about,
I lost 95% of my vision in about 5 months.
I had a very, very tough period of time,
until one day I figured
out how to stop being
a poorly functioning sighted person
and start being a highly
functioning blind person,
and then began doing
things that I'd never done
before I lost my sight, including sailing.
For anyone who thinks that
they can't do something,
it's too hard, it's too complicated,
it's too frustrating, I'm here to tell you
that's just not true.
Add a little courage, and you can do
just about anything.
(upbeat music)